sept députés européens que nous
accueillons ce matin dans son caddie
bonjour louis joseph manscour député
socialiste au parlement de bruxelles il
y aura le renouvellement de ce parlement
de ce parlement ce sera à la fin du mois
de mai le 26 mai plus exactement mais
quelle usine à gaz cette élection
européenne pour les socialistes qui
cherche désespérément à trouver et des
alliés et une tête de liste il y à t'il
le feu dans la maison de la rose rouge
permettez moi monsieur lé temps avant de
vous répondre de sacrifier à la
tradition et de souhaiter et des voeux
de bonne année à tous vos auditeurs aux
éditions de martinique que la première
alors début de réussite pour le parti
socialiste aussi aussi c'est vrai vous
l'avez dit le prince socialiste bon que
sa venue ne se porte pas très bien mais
il en fait il sait des cycles c'est
cyclique
il a le soleil vingtaine d'années le
parti socialiste tenait dé devant des
médias aujourd'hui la situation
difficile mais il faut moins de 7%
travaux d'extension de voter oui mais ce
sont des intentions de vote nous allons
voir maintenant avec tout ce qui se
passe avec les jaunes et où nous nous
verrons que les socialistes même si il
reste faible aux potentialités il
l'esprit l'idée socialiste demeure et il
n'y a pas de doute que nous allons user
courant parce qu'on aurait pu penser que
vous auriez pu votre parti aurait pu
reprendre des couleurs avec cette
manifestation des gilets jaunes cette
contestation vis-à-vis du gouvernement
du président de la république mais là il
ya des tensions
oui effectivement la multiplicité des
partis et ça ne favorise pas notamment
des partis de gauche qui sont très
divisés ne favorise pas une telle
situation mais en fait on va attendre
on va attendre le 26 mai envers vous
voulez être résolument optimiste oui je
suis de nature optimiste
autre particularité de ce scrutin du 26
mai il n'y a plus il n'ya plus de
circonscriptions régionales désormais
c'est une liste unique le risque est
très grand pour que nous n'ayons plus de
moonwalk et non à bruxelles
vous l'avez bien dit et je pense que
c'est une erreur de du président de la
république le considérer qu'il vaut
mieux qu'il ait des 10 national c'est
vrai qui comme son parti n'a pas des
plantations
locale donc la meilleure solution c'est
de présenter une liste nationale mais
nous risquons de ne pas voir nos
territoires représentés déjà ils sont
représentés bien difficilement sur des
buts et on se souvient de ces luttes
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
c'est que les populations
les électeurs vont se désintéresser de
plus en plus de des élections
européennes parce que ils n'ont pas le
sentiment d'avoir une sorte de proximité
déjà qui n'est pas réel en ce moment
joseph manscour avant de commencer cet
entretien vous me rappeliez que ça fait
quand même 42 ans que vous êtes élu que
ce soit en tant que maire conseiller
général député est ce que vous êtes donc
un sage sage de cette vie politique est
ce que vous êtes consultant au moment où
vous allez rendre ce tablier du
parlement européen est ce que vous êtes
consulter pour savoir qui de chez nous
pourrait être placé en position éligible
vous savez chez nous en martinique
d'abord un oui je vous ai dit que la
situation est très difficile vous avez
dit que la moins parti qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas à nous de marquer quand même
car beaucoup de difficultés en ce moment
donc les plats seront excessivement cher
et c'est là où je reprends justement à
ces soupçons mode de scrutin c'est que
ce sont les partis nationaux qui vont
décider de la représentation des
territoires
donc il ya de fortes chances que nous
ayons beaucoup de difficultés à avoir et
martiniquais est ce qu'on vous consulte
vous louis joseph manscour est ce qu'on
vous demande en tant que anciens en tant
que celui de quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
d'expérience
si je vous le dis c'est parce que je
suis membre du comité national du parti
socialiste c'est que je sens que les
choses seront difficiles et qu'on n'est
pas seront très chères
il faut donner le bac contre la
guadeloupe contre la guyane et la
batucada manuel prendre contre
l'ensemble des détails
c'est ce qu'il faut frein parce que vous
venez de dire sept ou huit broussard ça
fait soixante dix neuf députés parce que
nous aurons 79 députés je parle de la
france soit 70 députés ce qui fait que
les plats seront excessivement cher
marge je souhaite quand même que la
martinique ou la guadeloupe la guyane
l'outre-mer soit représenté et si
possible dans chaque territoire afin
qu'ils aient une visibilité alors
l'europe
louis joseph manscour l'union européenne
il ya des dossiers qui suscitent
régulièrement des inquiétudes
l'utilisation des fonds européens on a
beaucoup parlé on a parlé dégagement
d'office y un peu plus d'un an les
milieux économiques avait plus que
fortement exprimé leur mécontentement de
la gestion des dossiers puis finalement
en fin d'année dernière les voyants sont
repassés au vert semble-t-il vaut le
député européen le martiniquais qui est
à bruxelles dites nous votre lecture à
vous concernant l'utilisation de ces
fonds européens
il faut dire aussi que les collectivités
et notre singulièrement celle de matinée
que ont rencontré quand même quelques
dizaines le départ puisqu'on a voté très
tard le pays et la complexité des
procédures mais cela ne saurait
justifier justement l'insuffisante de
consommation des crédits moi je le dis
nous ne sommes pas les meilleurs élèves
de la de la classe oui mais ceci étant
mauvais ça franchement mauvais disons le
nom c'est à dire si on compare à
d'autres régions non non mais nous ne
sommes pas les meilleurs de la classe et
nous sommes parmi les derniers de la
classe
ceci étant le problème qui se pose est
que nous avons six ans pour consommer
825000 835 millions de de fonds
européens
quatre ans se sont écoulés nous avons
consommé à peu près 40%
il laisse deux ans pour consommer 60 %
est-ce que nous allons pouvoir consommer
et 60% à 2 ans tout le problème est là
heureusement qu'ils auront on prévoit
qu'il n'y a pas de dégagement d'office
cette année c'est déjà une bonne chose à
de dégagement d'office et a dit quand
l'argent ou par prêt pour faire simple
donc on peut dire que il pas durant
cette année et a eu beaucoup de progrès
on a beaucoup travaillé mais il reste
encore plus de 500 millions de crédits à
consommer en deux ans qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire louis joseph moscow pour que
ce que le procès soit plus efficace
oui alors que davantage de personnes par
exemple assez à la septième pour gérer
les dossiers non je pense que la
commission a prévu
dit l'hôte de la confiance de cayenne
qu'il faut alléger les procédures
c'est vrai que les procédures sont quand
même très très lourde et très compliqué
il faudrait aussi que les collectivités
puissent permettra à leurs agents
d'aller de temps en temps à boussay les
voir un peu comment ça se passe pour
faire avancer les dossiers
parce que c'est difficile pour nous nous
députés européens quand nous demandons
plus le crédit on nous dit mais oui mais
vous ne connaissez pas d'être ai dit que
vous avez vous demandé plus c'est ça le
problème
mais sinon j'espère bien que de plus en
plus les présidents des collectivités
singulièrement celle de la martinique
ferons en sorte qu' il y ait une plus
grande efficacité auprès d'allah j'ai
sonné il faut réécrire la feuille de
route dans le processus
certainement la grammaire comme on dit
dans la grammaire de l'utilisation des
fonds européens façon martinique
pression dans la technique je pense que
oui il faut y porte parce que il trop de
chefs d'entreprises trop de 2,2 de
l'association qui sollicitent des des
fonds viennent me voir parfois et me
dire oui mais nous avons déposé des
dossiers ça fait deux ans on n'a pas de
crédit on n'a rien on ne répond pas il a
désormais lioration a faim il faut pas
il faut pas le nier il faut pas faire de
l'auto suffisance
il faut au contraire dire que moi même
si nous avons travaillé beaucoup il doit
encore beaucoup à faire pour
l'efficacité dans la gestion des crises
parmi les sujets qui fâchent qui crispe
l'octroi de mer le système actuel de
taxation produits entrant sur notre
territoire
existera encore jusqu'en 2020 si je ne
me trompe et déjà cet enjeu de savoir
s'il sera reconduit ou peuple est ce qu
on en reparlera avant le scrutin du 26
mai prochain
c'est un bras de mer c'est un véritable
serpent de mer et moi je lui ai dit je
le dis je le dis ici j'espère que les
gens m'écoutent
c'est que l'octroi de mer de plus en
plus chahutées de plus en plus des des
voix s'élèvent des députés seidel des
états s'élèvent pour contester
l'octroi de mer donc vous voyez bien
depuis 30 ans se bat et en allemand
prédécesseurs ont la renouveler on s'est
battu là encore une liste de deux
produits
tout ça c'est bien mais il faut se dire
que à 2015 il ya eu quand même 140
députés qui ont voté contre + 150 qui se
sont abstenus on n'avait jamais vu ça
cela voulait dire qu' il faudra qu'on
qu'on commence à réfléchir je l' ai dit
ça sur une discussion au sein de
l'hémicycle
et c'est là que tout le monde risque de
dire pourquoi ne pas mettre une telle
taxe pour les île grecque portugaise
italienne mais mais mais mais il a
demandé ja a depuis très longtemps
nos députés nous disent mais oui mais
pourquoi pourquoi vos des antilles est
pas non ceci étant avant tout cas ce qui
nous reste c'est que nous disons pas
qu'il faut pas qu'il y ait pour des îles
grecques etc
nous disons simplement il faut maintenir
l'octroi de mer parce que c'est un outil
qu'est même qui est très important pour
la gestion des collectivités et on y
revient à la question du début avec qui
pour mieux nous défendre de tels sujets
il faudrait donc de quelques de nos
régions à la ba à bruxelles pour parler
oui je souhaite qu'il y ait des robots
dédiés des élus régionaux mais vous
savez même si nous sommes trois à
défendre auprès de mr si on n'avait pas
aussi derrière vous des groupes
politiques etc montrent rien faire donc
c'est bien d'avoir des élus mais c'est
bien aussi d'avoir des relais c'est bien
d'avoir des des collègues des camarades
dans des groupes qui nous soutiennent
parce que nous sommes toi donc et à 751
députés après le 26 mai que ferez vous
joseph manscour est bien géré ans chez
moi ouais ben j'ai du mal à croire qu
après 42 ans de politique vous ne
resterez que chez vous à regarder la
télévision ou à la gauloise autre vidéo
basée sur le jeu n'est pas gênant alors
je sais qu'elle est toujours les gens
viennent se confier aux jeunes et à
baden par la politique mais une chose
qui est certaine je peux vous confier
nous aussi je ne veux plus être élus
ouais je crois que ce soit je veux
rentrer chez moi je vais je vous dis
c'est la stricte et vous disposerez
votre parole vos conseils pour ceux qui
viennent derrière quoi part oui je pense
que c'est la mission de tout homme de
d'apporter des réponses et des conseils
aux c'est très attentif à l'élection
municipale de trinité oui oui mais je
suis traité comme tout électeur et comme
tout citoyen merci louis joseph manscour
d'avoir été ce matin avec nous rappelle
que vous êtes députée européenne
jusqu'au 26 mai de cette année merci
bonne journée merci à vous